le 6 novembre dernier le skipper louis
burton originaire de rambouillet
prenaient le départ du vendée globe 2016
à bord de son imoca bureau vallée pour
partager les aventures du skipper dans
le siège social de bureau vallée aux
clayes-sous-bois une trentaine
d'employés se sont improvisés capitaine
sur le jeu virtual regatta une
simulation en ligne du vendée globe
ouverte à tous créé en 2006 parmi ces
marins d'eau douce on retrouve le
directeur de projet nicolas str grecque
j'avais envie de suivre louis tous les
jours et donc de faire suivre aussi les
aventures de louis à ma famille et
virtual regatta c'est un bon moyen de se
coller à l'aventuré sans subir tous les
tous les aléas cour peut avoir en mer
sur ce jeu nicolas doit se mettre dans
la peau d'un véritable skipper les
joueurs ont les mêmes vents et la même
météo en temps réel il faut aussi régler
ses voiles et fixer son cap
régulièrement son objectif est clair
comme les eaux du pacifique terminer
devant louis burton
j'ai pris quelques quelques quelques
options un peu différente de louis et
maintenant on est complètement collés au
bout de quarante journée on est
quasiment au même niveau
sachant qu on n'en doutait pas du tout
partie sur la même option début c'est
qui les plus forts que moi mais mais
j'ai la chance de ne pas avoir tous les
tous les cas au qui peut y avoir en mer
donc oui effectivement
j'aimerais bien arriver avant lui les
deux concurrents viennent d'atteindre le
stade de la mi course au large de
l'australie rendez vous début février
pour savoir qui remportera la victoire
entre nicolas et le navigateur yves
binois